foreign
yeah because typically I'm looking for
these things to be like two-hour
meetings at
good morning all
uh welcome to the special committee on
commissions and committees
uh
I'm representative fatusic
representative
is out in Spain
celebrating Cinco de Mayo and a wedding
so uh to get started I'd like to do a
little house house clean housekeeping
housekeeping uh
we have been remiss in the fact that we
do not have a committee Clerk
and I would like to uh well
representative Rambo is not here yet
and was she did she notify anybody that
she was not going to be here
I think
I know I I uh I gotta I gotta eat text
from some representative Wilhelm
I have to remember I can't call him that
in meeting okay these I have to be
formal
and uh yes I'm going to ask
representative Rambo to be our uh
committee Clerk
and I would hope she would say yes uh
that's first the first bit of
housekeeping the second bit of
housekeeping is the next two meetings
we'll start at 1 pm
they will hopefully be finished by 3 pm
because for me to make morning meetings
as you have already seen
is tough for me because I have other
things going on
excellent
okay uh
so in order to make that official we
have to have a clerk who takes notes
so
all right uh we are here today primarily
uh
two there we are
I representative that's that's fine I
would I was advised that you might be a
touch a touch late
but that's okay uh
and I'm going to ask you if you would
consider being our committee Clerk
so thank you we appreciate that do we
have to vote on that
no
okay you are duly appointed
thank you
okay our meetings from now on are going
to be from that the next two are going
to be at one o'clock on Monday not in
the morning
because a lot of us have way other stuff
and some of us that are oh as old as me
takes a while to get that motor running
Monday morning
so
okay uh
one of our one of our primary purposes
today is to have Dave aluconis
Enlighten us and try to help us come up
with a framework
for the drafting attorneys to help them
get through all the knot holes that they
have to get through
so Dave I know you say you had some
information for us so
it's all yours
foreign
thank you Mr chairman I have brought
with me today uh two of our drafting
attorneys we have Courtney esbar and
Hannah and Jack here uh to also answer
questions why don't you guys come right
on up
just move the microphone as necessary I
I did send this uh information out uh
this is the same as I send out by email
if anyone would like paper copies we're
here okay
thank you
and what you'll find in that packet
again that's the same as I sent out by
email last week is an excerpt from our
drafting manual concerning uh the
writing of these bills and then most of
this is uh also accepted from uh the
manual in the appendices which are
examples of commissions and committees
and things like that so this is what
guides us in
the drafting of it so these entities
Courtney sure
the front line one of the front line
dealing with the members coming in
so my name is Courtney eschbach I'm one
of the drafting attorneys in the office
of legislative Services I've been in
there for 18 years
um study committees usually what happens
is a member will come in and request a
study committee or a study commission
we'll talk about exactly what that
member wants to study I'll give an
example because I've worked on it for a
few years there's been a study committee
on dog grooming regulations
um and so at that point if you think of
it like a flowchart
um we ask who they want to be on the
committee and if they want it to just be
legislators then great we do I think the
standard is three members of the House
three members of the Senate
um we come up with some duties that they
want them to study that's it it goes
into session law if it passes both
houses
um the if they want members outside of
the legislature
we have to codify it in the rsas and so
we'll talk about sort of where's the
best place for that to fit who they want
on it last year a new rule or a new
statute was added that the number of
members who are non-legislative members
cannot be greater than the number of
legislative members
um so several people have gotten around
that by saying well notwithstanding that
law and then
you know they put as many people as
they'd like
um but those because those commissions
tend to be very short-lived you know so
again taking the dog grooming as an
example
um you know you have your 10 people on
the commission and you want them to
report back
um it doesn't make sense for them to
live in the statute sort of forever and
ever so we Sunset them or we perspective
repeal them usually one to two years out
um and that is essentially the
difference between the two and how we
approach them we always defer to the
members on which one
um which one they would prefer to have
because I know some people have
constituents that they want on the
commissions or committees some people
have
um people that they definitely want to
give input into the committee we usually
do advise them they don't have to be a
member to give input but you know again
we recognize that every case is
different so that is essentially how we
handle it Hannah I don't know did I
leave anything out
yeah so I have the a base form of what a
study committee looks like so that would
be
I think so a version of a study
committee
um so which is going to be a session law
not uh codified with an RSA number and
so just going through line by line you
know they there's a establish a
committee to study blank and dog
grooming regulations could be one of
them and then there's the form three
members of the House three members of
the Senate and as you all know that is
massaged frequently especially by the
Senate they'll usually bring it down to
one member
um and then the duties of the committee
is really where the nuts and bolts of us
talking to the members of what they want
do you want them to study what the fees
should be what the training should be
for dog grooming
um yeah what other states might be doing
any proposed you know if they want to
submit proposed legislation and if it is
a session law study committee rather
than a codified commission those duties
is where we would say consult with the
veterinarians Association of the State
uh consult with a member of The Grooming
community of the state rather than
making them a voting member which is
usually what happens in a codified
commission and so we've seen many of the
same ideas promoted in both ways and
it's really just up to the member which
Avenue they would like to go with um in
in essence they are the same except for
the voting members when it comes down to
it so yeah we are open to any questions
thank you Mr chairman you may have said
this but
um
are there Sunset requirements
on that
um
form that they have to go through I mean
is it required to put a Sunset date
I don't think it is required it's done I
don't think it's required anything in
Statue I can't think of anything off but
it does you know when we talk about our
job and our duty towards the statutes we
want to make sure that what's in the
rsas is actually what's current law so
if you put a study commission into the
rsas and it fulfills its duty but it's
still hanging out there it's it's an
appendix basically right like it's
serving no purpose
um so we try as a way to keep the RSA
sort of compact readable and
understandable by the public if it has
served its purpose if they've done their
final report then it's time for it to
prospectively repeal
but there is no requirement that it do
so
and there are sorry there are
commissions that have existed in
perpetuity like the commission on Native
American Affairs is one of them
um but there are committees in both the
house and the Senate every year that
will bring up a number of commissions
that they know aren't meeting regularly
they are struggling to get membership
um that they will ask to Sunset that
hadn't had a sunset provision in them so
which is why when we meet with members
we try to counsel them on do you want
this commission to meet for five years
do you think the need will be over in
five years and put in the prospective
repeal
um or do you want it to live in
perpetuity or you put in the perspective
repeal of five years and then somebody
can come in and amend that prospective
repeal and extend it after that too so
you've seen a number of flavors but
there are a number of commissions that
have been around for you know 20 plus
years that have existed in perpetuity
okay thank you ah
you have a question
um
yes yes in the XML is it in the packet
no because that's it's a it's part of
the computer program the software so
it's not
yes
it's not like a PDF form it's it's a
different animal
representative Abel
so there are um a couple of people I
think who weren't here at the at the
last meeting and so I just wanted to put
some context I think into why we were
wanting you to come and part of it is
that during the drafting process
um
I mean you guys are you you do the
drafting but then you know the
legislature it has to go through the
process and then everybody else
basically has to live with what's
drafted and so I think what we're trying
to figure out is
you know what you have in your templates
at this point what sort of things are
kind of pain points as they go through
the legislative process and then what
sorts of things we could work with you
on so that we understand what the
template is especially for legislators
who are coming in so they understand
what they're going to be asked when they
come in with a great idea and it's not
really to get into the the substance of
what they once studied although we want
to make sure that when they come into
you they when one of the first questions
there's they're they're asked and maybe
you asked this already is has this been
studied before have you seen the report
and why does this not satisfy you
because you know there's really an
interest in not developing as many of
these as we um as we
have been right
um but I all anyway that was one thing
sure and that's that is an excellent
point um but I would say
if the new member comes in I'm actually
not in a position because I'm hearing it
for the first time I don't know if it's
been studied before and as far as I know
there's not a good easy way to quickly
pull that up while a member is sitting
with me
um if there was a way that would be a
great way to do that
well so just give me a follow-up so that
but that's part of what we're really
working on here
um I you know I think I think there's
been a lot of work being done to try to
um
figure out what commissions exist and
have them equally available to everybody
and then just to increasingly make
available through research by the member
I I mean I think our idea here is that
it's not your as the drafter it's not
your responsibility to do the research
before they walk in the door that's why
I would say when they come in they're
like okay step one if you want to do
this have you talked to OLS do you know
that this hasn't been done before
because you guys have a million things
to do right so that's just also part of
our understanding better of the process
and what tools we can put into place to
make it easier
um
for everybody I mean we did just pass
this statute and there is in that
statute The Five-Year repeal requirement
so
I mean part of the thing is I think when
people come in they don't necessarily
know all the they know what they want to
study they don't know all the scoop and
so there's a lot of
I I don't know procedural questions that
when when you give the the fine the
draft to them they may not have even
thought of so we just want to make sure
that the draft
has as much in it to get rid of the pain
points as it as it can anyway we can we
can talk about all of that but and the
the only other thing I want to say is I
think we're really sensitive to the fact
that you guys are drafting attorneys
you're not members
so
correctly point out when we're you know
that this we have these small Windows
when we're accepting your requests and
we're when most of those requests come
in via email now uh probably at 80 90 at
least uh or via email uh so that
requires some back and forth sometimes
uh which means you have to put it aside
while you're waiting for for a response
uh which sometimes comes quite later in
the process
um and but that's it's a rapid fire
period that we're going through and when
we receive those requests we want our
goal is to turn that around and make it
into a true LSR uh that same same day uh
so that it doesn't carry over that's uh
I'm sorry can I just clarify and by make
it into a true LSR meaning it has a
number and a title not that it's
completely drafted because we want to
make sure it's out there in public so
that people are not duplicating effort
and then as soon as in the house as soon
as it becomes an LSR
we will batch them and put them on the
website so that it helps us internally
also because we can look at that list
because these seven folks uh are
handling various various requests that
uh may not know what's going on in the
other in the other cubes in the office
okay uh thank you
um
as representative evil
mentioned and we've talked
the research
that should go into the LSR
has it been studied before what was the
outcome who who did it when did they do
it uh was it done 15 years ago does it
need to be done again you know because
of times change
that's one of the things that is
frustrating us
because
the same thing gets punched in over and
over and over and it's not your fault
it's the system
and we want to
our job to do two things kill off the
ones that are dead and prevent ones that
should be dead
so we're we're working right now on
preventing bills to be drafted that
they did a study five years ago there
was an outcome this we don't need this
and it's not your job to say so
because your job is to draft new new
lsrs and you don't even know if this
thing was
up in Anne's back closet
which which this where all these guys
are stored I mean I was up there almost
oh
she said if she saw my face it was oh my
God I mean it's walls and walls and
walls of of bills study commissions
committees
if I may OLS research does very much the
same thing and it would be it would be
lovely if the members would ask OLS
research has this been studied not
necessarily by a commission or Committee
just by us internally where we have
provided it to members and I know
frustration has been with house
committee services that members will not
will ask because committee services to
research the very same same thing that
OLS is being has been asked and it ends
up being two offices doing exactly the
same thing uh which is uh obviously not
very efficient way of doing things
representative walls
foreign
keeping your research but you're not
here to wait on us here to take what we
have and put it into some form of we can
work on so thank you very much for that
um I I wonder with all these commissions
and maybe it's not
argument to study
well I've heard of this before I've
heard this Ada to mentioned before or
whatever
isn't that Our obligation to find out
through research if I know I mean so if
it's a duplicate in the year yes oh I'm
sorry
no it's a parliamentary inquiry yeah
that's a standing joke with us okay
great
no so if it's
if it's absolutely I'll say actually
someone else filed that it's
representative Abel you should go speak
with her
um if I know that it was done in the
past year or so
um I will actually mention it because
I'll say oh hey you know they did a
commission on that you know did you take
a look at it but I have to know about it
and that's part of the hard when there's
seven of us drafting you know 1200 bills
like you don't keep everyone in the
front of your brain and especially in
the week or two week window that we have
that we're taking requests you're just
kind of trying to get things into the
system as quickly as you can so
um you know if I know I'm absolutely I'm
absolutely going to say oh yeah they you
know we did something like that last
year you know but nine times out of ten
I don't remember right in the moment
because there's just so much going on
oh
no and can I follow up to that I mean
I'd say one thing if I had a nickel for
every time I said have you gone to
research
um and the person said no my student
loans would get paid off after 18 years
it is a valuable resource but I think
the other thing is and we're not in a
position to really say this but if there
is especially a very specific question
you know encouraging members to just
call the department you don't need a
study commission to to ask the
Department of Agriculture about why the
fee structure for pesticides is the way
it is
um you know you really can do that
research and any of the research arms
are to help you with that but again
we're not in a position where we can
really say I can't do this for you you
just need to make a phone call so
anything that in the orientation in
leadership and caucus that you can do to
encourage especially new members that
you know hey don't feel be afraid to
reach out and ask your questions you'll
get a better product if you talk to the
people yourselves you know I think that
that would also be very helpful
and I may representative wall we we do
try to tell that orientated orientation
in fact Mila's always sitting with me
and we're talking about research but as
you all know that small orientation
period for new members who have no
experience it's really drinking from a
fire hose and it's it's overwhelming uh
it's we try not to get too deep in the
weeds although you know we can do that
believe me uh it and it really needs to
be a continuing education form and we
had
been looking at doing more than covet
hit and we're still kind of recovering
from that and of course this year has
been a very very busy session uh for us
uh from from the time we started
drafting or taking in the requests in
the fall it's been non-stop so it is
something I will say though that uh
it appears that we have more
newer members requesting research right
now for next year than we've seen in the
past
that's right as Ann points out
orientation came after for the new
members after the the drafting the
filing period for the house this year
actually
um so I think just in terms of research
I think we're going to be working more
and more to try to
make better the tools for people to go
online to archived studies themselves
because
um and and I think house committee
Services has been working on it I mean
the more we can get that digitized and
the other thing is that I think we need
to sharpen and look a little more
closely on our search tools on the
general court website because I have
looked I mean I I I'll look for things
in every way I can think of and I've
been pretty creative and I still won't
find something that I know is is there
um so I think we really
we have to do better with what we have
online so that people I mean you the
other thing I can imagine is that OLS is
inundated with research requests in the
two days before is a filing period you
know and so but I guess the other thing
I just wanted to say is I I don't think
there's anybody on the committee that
wants to invade your Turf in particular
but I think the more we can sort of
snuff out the problems that will be that
people are going to walk in with to you
guys if we can give them a sheet and we
can say look you're going to be asked
this you're going to be asked this
you're going to be asked this and you
really should be thinking about these
things when you're creating these these
study committees like who is going to be
the appointing authority what about the
repeal date what specifically do you
want studied I mean one thing we've
talked about here already is that some
of these commissions they create they
put people they put entities on them
that the entities don't from their
mission they don't want to be on them
or they're they're asked like to be on
10 or 15 things that they can't possibly
do so one thing I would say is have you
talked to the people you want to put on
this thing
um I think the real challenge is to talk
people off the threshold of creating
these huge commissions and having them
fully appreciate that a legislative
study committee can do really good work
too but the other thing I want to ask
you you really don't feel empowered to
say to somebody have you spoken to the
department or have you spoken to
somebody if they come in with these
study ideas I absolutely feel empowered
but once they say no there's not there's
nothing I can really say except okay so
I think that's also I think part of the
challenge
yeah
if I may I understand well the pro the
problems here and representative working
for a couple of years here and all of
your staff whether it be house staff we
all I know what's what the problems that
these things have uh have caused and you
know poor deaf Childs you know I see
those I see those appointment emails
from her and Sunday morning at five
o'clock in the morning that she's
sending out and that's it's that's all
it seems she does I know she does an
awful lot more but uh those those things
are non-stop uh on the appointments uh
to to the commissions and committees so
I'm aware and I certainly when we
certainly want to be part of the how to
make it better I don't know if there's a
solution but it's how to make it better
and one of the things that some of us
been talking about in our in our shop is
to at least have some sort of flyer or
something that has those sort of
questions and that's and I don't want I
don't it's I don't want to go jump into
that at this right now other than give
it some some thought because I think
this committee uh
needs to inform whatever that
document looks like when we when we have
it available for members
I think your checklist ideas yeah we
were
[Music]
um
idea
to be part of the proactive how to do
this the right way that you don't need
commissions is to have for orientation
to have a check sheet that when you want
to have an LSR drafted these are the
steps that you should be taking
did you do your house research did you
do your LSI OLS research
has this been a committee commission
before when was it a committee it
answers the questions
before you go to you with an idea have
you walked this road before
so Jim excuse me representative copault
um thank you Mr chairman
um so so the other challenge I think
that we're dealing with is that uh
committees commissions uh Etc are
an effective way to gently kill a bell
or to gently
um redirect a bill to you know in a way
that
doesn't hurt feelings as as badly as
just killing it and so I I guess I'm
curious first of all to what extent is
this a problem with the initial drafting
process versus to what extent is this a
problem with the amendment process if we
have a checklist it needs to be an
amendment checklist as well
um because I think that's where a lot of
this stuff comes up yeah
I agree
ment
to uh really tackle but our job will be
to you know dampen the enthusiasm for
creating I I mean I honestly I think the
statutory commissions are the ones that
are the most
difficult for staff for management uh
you know administratively
and everything I have less of a problem
with the with the study committees just
because they're they go fast they
automatically Sunset yeah
um but I mean I just made a and these
are things you guys all talk about like
make sure that the terms of office for
the people appointed are very clearly
delineated right
um and I know in our statute that we
just passed and I just I didn't see that
referenced but in your worksheets here
but I'm sure that you know it has not
that section has not been updated to
reflect that but we are keenly aware of
it yeah
um but it's like sometimes a
representative might be appointed to
something but not in their
representative status and so it's not
co-turned you know they're it I mean
I've just sat on commissions where
people are really confused about their
term of office and I think we'll be able
to correct that going forward but just
going backward
um I I mean speaking for myself
personally I'd really like to see in the
template and then in what comes out for
commissions that the House and Senate
standing committees that are responsible
for the jurisdiction always will get a
copy of the report I mean now we say
that the governor and the you know and
the clerks and the library get them I
think I mean I think the other point of
this committee is to make sure that the
people that need to get these reports
are getting them and part of that is the
standing committees I mean maybe ledge
admin should always get them so that so
that you
um have them and then this whole thing
about make sure each appointee has an
appointee authority we just passed a
bill I think last week that there are no
appointing authorities for a couple of
the people that are in the in the in the
bill
um and then what I just said Can does
your entity want
to participate
you know and then things that I think
Representatives have to be sensitive is
is is lobbyists really pushing for
commissions versus study committees
that's not really your domain
um and then things that I've heard from
people is what what do you want in a
report a lot of these things it just
says you have to report by November 1st
but it's not like clear what uh
representative thinks should be in the
report sometimes people are um are
floundering who is the convening
authority is it the legislature or is it
an agency and the other thing I've heard
is people are having agencies convene
them because they're they're they wanted
to happen but that cost the agency's
money
um
and the other thing for me is that I
think that if it's a Senate Bill the
Senate has to staff the things and not
the house
and I saw one of your samples here which
I liked a lot it said right in there it
was a Senate bill and it said a senator
shall be the first named member so
representative Abel in our
um template you know it actually says
that the first meeting shall be called
by the first named and if it's a house
committee it is the first named House
member if it's a senate committee it is
the first named Senate member so I'm not
quite sure where this committee or
commission is that a department is
convening it the only way that that
usually happens is if the member
themselves asks oh no I want and some
they want this this to happen yeah
um so I just wanted I wanted to clarify
like we already that is already part of
part and parcel of what we're doing
that's why I know okay great
um but the one other thing that I would
say is all of this education is great
um but we had a portal you know around
the time of orientation that had lots of
educational
um you know videos and documents and
things on it I actually pointed several
members to it when they would ask
questions and that those educational
materials are only so good in so far as
people are using them and that's where I
think it's important again for
leadership for the caucuses you know for
the older members to really really hit
home like you need to use these
resources and you know put them out and
available as much as possible instead of
just relying on orientation to which is
drinking out of a fire hose and relying
on orientation to say hey here's how you
do things okay great have a great
session so I don't know we're not in a
position to really tell you how to do
that but I just do think you know
repetition is is key so anything you can
do to keep hitting these points with
your member of you know here's your
checklist because oh he left
representative copal has a great point
that there are kind of these life cycles
of okay they all come in during filing
and then we get crossover and there's
definitely a larger number of oh we're I
want to try and save my bill or we're
going to kill a gently or whatever it is
the politics we don't really ask
um but there is a large number of
conversions right before crossover and
then again right before the end of the
year
um so making sure that that checklist is
always kind of floating around in The
Ether for members I think would be very
helpful
uh thank you Mr chair um yeah I think so
we come up with a checklist it seems
like orientation obviously but there are
many returning members who are not going
to orientation at that point or when we
never have under you know it was never
communicated to them so it seems like it
either needs to be you know I don't know
if it'll be the speaker that
electronically disseminating it to the
whole house or tasking committee chairs
with you know
when you know you're voting so we're
gonna have handing them the form the
same way we have to do burbs or for a
calendar or anything like that
um it seems like something we could
try to communicate through some
different Avenues yeah because I think
it's right orientation new people are
too new to even know what they don't
know and then other people are not
necessarily back in that space well and
it's been exacerbated in that four years
ago with covet the system got blown out
of the water and then now we're in the
second cycle after that where we have
new members that haven't seen the place
hum the way it used to and uh so that's
the the turnover that we have that's
over half the members of the house that
have not experienced
things running the way they should they
should be with the institutional memory
that members uh once had and that is we
see that as a problem uh in the way
members are requesting or dealing with
lsrs amendments uh and and the like it's
our end of the process we're seeing a
lot of that and we have to inform the
members of how certain things are
supposed to work yes
maybe representative will kind of answer
this but am I correct that if you were
to go on to the general court website to
do a search the way we do for rsas or as
far as we could not just do a search for
a keyword first study committee that may
have existed at some point you can but
it just doesn't work
because that seems like obviously the
easiest way to weed out for people to do
their own piece to this huge yeah
okay representable thank you thank you
Mr chairman thank you again
um I think we're all pretty much on the
same page here
um I think the one step forward we've
come to so far today is that we need a
brochure or handout of some kind if we
don't actually have continuing education
and actually the problem with continuing
education as much as I believe in the
people who should show up who don't so
so if we have a handout of some sort and
every single mail slot and reminding
people the process to follow what you
can do what you should do and what you
should not do I think that's the biggest
thing we can do it's very difficult to
navigate
uh our website in some instances and a
lot of people just give up so if we have
a handout you know there's a lot to be
said still for paper so I'm with you on
that thank you
okay representative well I mean I think
this is a conversation yes
um I just I I guess the other thing I
wanted to emphasize is that we're also
going to be working on something to give
to committee chairs with a lot of the
same perhaps questions so that you know
they go through your process but a lot
of the ways that they test the issues
within the committee as to whether to
create a study committee or not
you know the Committees will be going
through the science saying I mean I I
just think this checklist idea where
everybody's sort of on the same
wavelength um on what is going to be
needed in these things is is um is
really helpful and I just you know there
is just this thing when speakers when
there is a transfer of power things get
lost and I think that the more that we
could really establish solid policy that
exists regardless of who is in the in
the speaker's office that this is like
the way you do these things it'll all be
to the um to the good and I just I mean
it's great if we can all just keep
talking and then you know sort of smooth
out the process in the long term the
goal is to do the best study committees
we can get useful information and um but
decrease staff and legislative time to
the extent possible if I if I I may on
that point a great example of that was
the what did the RSA 1449 that has the
majority legislative members cap and as
you all have seen the creative way to
get around that is the notwithstanding
1449 you do whatever you want
um so we've been talking in the office
how do we encourage people to follow the
statutes that they themselves have
passed and house rules is of one place
where we can say well in the house rules
that you agreed to on organization day
that's how we get around duplicate
filings
um in the first instance so maybe an
Avenue as well as the continuing
education and reminding committee chairs
is coming up with a house rule about
commissions or committees in whatever
way you all see fit I mean you've seen
it all you've seen the creative ways and
maybe different delineations you'd like
to make on what's acceptable and not
acceptable but rules is another Avenue
where we can say no and we don't get to
say no very often or at least we get to
say no and then they come back and
they're like but I want to do it anyway
and we we do what you all want to do
usually so
so rules is a great way for us to say
well you all agreed an organization day
that this is how you want to proceed and
then in order to overturn a rule you
need two-thirds majority so
okay I and I do exercise that I have the
ability in the to say no to duplicative
bills or those that are substantially
similar and uh I and I I will do that
several times during the filing filing
period
and it takes that takes some doing
because I've got to look into the LSR
cards and it may have the same title but
essentially the same title but it may be
two very different things or it may have
two different titles and B essentially
the same thing so uh it takes it takes
some doing to understand that because
we're only looking I'm only at that
point only looking at what the concept
is that the member brought in and these
folks will come back to me if
if Courtney has two bills that had a
different title but they are in fact the
same and she'll let me know and I'll
look into it and I'll I'll send that
communication out saying sorry sorry I
can't allow that in and then the member
can go to the speaker for uh how is that
result
first of all
filings are private but if you see
something duplicative then how how does
that I will tell I will tell them
I will work if I will work with the
first one that came in as as uh being
the one that lives uh the second one I
will talk to the member and say I can't
allow that and I'll cite the house Rule
and uh and then it can be appealed to
the speaker in the case of the house
and then I will always refer them to the
house clerk's office for anything else
regarding rules
okay uh anything else on this subject
anybody else I
I force me but anyway
I mean the only thing I we about rules I
was a really good idea but in any given
term you re-adopt the rules
but as soon as I mean if we can just get
them like so they're standard I mean the
other challenge that I think we will
have is this obviously isn't a joint
committee it's a house committee
so you know we'll have to sort of work
with the Senate and try to try to um
try to work that out
I mean I don't
who could develop a checklist for us to
start with
us I don't know
um I mean it might be we could get ideas
from you and from Anne yeah I mean come
up with a checklist and we now have a
right a committee clerk who can gather
these guys
I mean I don't know
I
kind of thing or
yeah I mean I
I mean that would be fantastic and then
I mean I
the more that's disseminated the better
and I think I think you know if if
members are leaned on from all different
sides hopefully we'll come to a good
resolution but you're right I mean the
education in the front part it's just
really be proactive well and and
I mean in the house we have at least a
third turnover
ly every term so it's almost like you
have so the more standardized we can
make this
the better and we certainly need to be
working this together I don't want to
get out ahead of of no this is you're
the the center of this whole operation
right now and where kind of the the
this may inform what you would already
be doing if you're drafting a checklist
for us but I know you referenced the
sort of the computer program that you
have to do Fields drop downs whatever it
is
um would it be possible or would it be
useful for us to get screenshots of
those I mean I know you can't print it
out for us because it's not document but
if we could see what you have to fill
out
does that does that make sense I mean
because it would sort of just
no when they're drafting uh was saying
like he's you know got a programming so
that's why he couldn't print it for the
paper but if we could see what what
information you have to input yeah I
mean
we can we can print off uh blank I'm
gonna yeah yeah it looks like this right
the gray fields are where we fill stuff
in
um so I mean we can definitely get you a
copy of that I think it'd just be
helpful to see what isn't there in a way
right
um or help us think about what isn't
there so what you see on that the gray
again that's the fillable
the rest of the boilerplate that's
that's I mean
how we always change it from three
Senators to one you know so maybe there
isn't that yeah
it's not in that
it's available for us to fill that
Garden standard RV what are you studying
and what are your genes so section one
and section three generally
you can change everything else but the
things that prompt that we're prompting
to act
s bare minimum what do you want to study
really just what do you want to study it
set in two different
right and it's a forum it tells us what
the report is it tells who the reports
go to but especially since you wanted to
go to the standing committees that would
be something but but I think that's
exactly what I mean because we're not
going to be talking about the
substantive matter so much we're going
to be looking at the blanks that you
fill in So yeah so that we're sort of
all on the um on the same wavelength I
mean the other thing we should be
talking about is you know they come when
when are the effective dates of these
committees because a lot of times with
the commissions they'll say
they want to meet in 30 days or they
want to mean 45 days and you know
honestly that's just kind of
unreasonable if you have a 40 person
commission trying to get all your
appointments and then they have trouble
getting a quorum that is always up to
the sponsor because that is not part of
the boilerplate the boilerplate is it's
effective upon passage and there's that
the first meeting is called by the first
named in your case House member
um so we will have members who
are anxious to get started on studying
something who do want it to be 30 days
after passage or whatever and again sort
of you know we we can't say no that's
crazy
um so we have to we put it in and we may
advise and say okay well you know you've
got a lot of people here are you sure
you want to do that and I mean you know
your colleagues they say Damn the
Torpedoes and you do what they say so
it's a question you ask you don't just
like spit out the form and it has 45
days in it no there are no days the the
format says that the first named in your
case House member if it were a senate
sponsor would be the first name Senate
member calls the hearing there's oh with
I'm sorry it does say first within 45
days never mind that's what I thought so
because I mean I've seen a lot come out
and they say 45 days so I mean a lot of
commissions have the governor appointing
somebody and you know that can be the
longest time lag on Earth and right
right so I'm sorry so it is 45 days in
there but
the first yeah the first meeting is
called and I don't know that
especially how you do the Quorum it
doesn't necessarily mean everybody's
been appointed yet yeah and that's the
problem so one of the things to consider
in the timeline
to an extent when people want to get
going right away on some of these things
is that uh it takes a while for bills to
get up to the governor's office yeah and
a lot and even on on the New Hampshire
Public Radio last year I was screaming
at the radio in the car when the report
said well it's this particular bill has
now passed both houses it's on its way
to the governor's office and it has to
sign it by no no because it will be
August and exactly I just did this
exactly we had at the end of the session
when we're done on the 29th or whatever
it is and all of the bills that have
been adopted by both both houses and
they come back to us for enrollment it
will take us a month
to get through those to make sure that
they are in correct form we double check
everything in every bill before we send
send it up for enrollment uh so then it
goes and to the Secretary of State's
office but then it's still not presented
to the governor because there are other
steps involved so it's
they're they're I deal with members of
recession saying well why hasn't haven't
we heard about that in the governor's
office well it has got
because there's there's a lot to do
between that final day of session and it
getting to the governor's office well
and the other thing is the the report
date I've seen bills come through where
they want the report by September and
I'm like no you're lucky if you've
convened by that November 1st is the
default and that is in the 10 th but
again we'll have members who come in and
they're like we're going to go
so in fact I think I just did one in the
past couple days where it was change it
to September and it was like okay
you know and the Senate has asked in the
past that the report did be December and
so I mean December doesn't isn't bad but
September is insane
[Music]
and also I mean you run into the same
issue this year where you might or yeah
that you would run into this year if you
have a committee that's meeting and
their final report is due in November
but filing was in September so you've
got this odd crossover and so maybe you
tack on an amendment to something that
exists because you're anticipating the
report but then the Senate could there's
a whole lot of like date jockeying and
half the time it's you know just du jour
what does the member choose if they
heard from the lobbyist what does the
lobbyist one
um yeah and we're we're at the beck and
call with that
okay thank you uh
the second part of our Charter is to get
rid of obsolete
not meeting
committees commissions Etc
you're part of
the mission and and as part of that
mission now you guys can sit back if you
want or just stay up there it's up to
you
um
I was talking to a couple of the members
both last week and this week
is there a listing of committees and
commissions when they meet
and when is the last time they met
is there a listing anywhere that may be
you or maybe that's not a question for
us
that's why I said you can step back if
you wanted to
uh because we're looking as my uh
compatriot reminded me today that is the
primary mission for us to do is to get
rid of old archaic useless dead
dying committees and commissions that
haven't done anything and they're still
sitting on the books
and like I said and showed me the closet
well it's the size of a two bedrooms
that where all these things are and
some of them
obviously are still in effect
so is there
this listing and it's all yours thanks
representative
um for the record I'm Ann Fitzgerald
director of house Community Services I
have Jennifer four who's our assistant
director here as well and as you guys
see we've been with you through this
entire
um time so in any event um yes there is
that is what Deborah Childs our Deputy
uh chief of staff is working on and has
been working on since the day she walked
in here
three years ago is and we have worked
out on it with her as well to update
this master list what we have done
is historically Pam smarling who's be
one of our researchers here for over 30
years staffed representative Evil's last
two committees on commissions as well as
the one in 2010. so Pam for all the
issues here maintained a master list but
then speakers us maintained a list and
and other offices did so what Deborah
has done
um as our deputy chief has and also as
the person in charge of making all the
speakers appointments to
um all these different entities
has brought us all together to create a
master list that will be maintained with
I.T but we're in the process of still
developing that and so right now
um as you've mentioned you know
Deborah's appointments come through at 5
00 a.m she is working on a daily basis
making appointments to those over 200
commissions that exist
uh and and what representative evil had
done as we did also in the 2010
um committee on committee commissions is
to examine all of those correct groups
of evil you had a questionnaire that was
sent to all of those entities that
existed and said when are you meeting
what are you doing and you you were able
to get rid of a good number 60 something
correct
and so now we so we are so what
Deborah's doing is we're and we're all
these different offices are helping her
with this the clerk's office house
Community Services
um and I.T to combine this finalists for
all of you but it is taking time and as
you know because we're in the middle
session trying to put this all together
so we are in the process of doing that
we did
um and I I will
check with Deborah she's had at least
six meetings with I.T to um
create this system
and as we um as you saw when we did our
first meeting with all of you and we did
the um presentation on all the aspects
of what we do she had been coordinating
all of that as well
so I will check with Debra on the
timeline as we can get this at least a
draft to you so you can see but
sometimes she is also in the process in
fact I just talked with her this morning
that she is contacting some of those
groups on her own saying well when is
the last time you met because some of
these groups have finished their work
and and they don't have a repeal they
may want to put in legislation to create
a repeal
so um we will get that number to you as
soon as possible or that list yeah that
would be that would be great it gives us
something to to start with but because
obviously there's committees and
commissions that
are sitting out there they haven't met
they're supposed to meet you know every
three months they haven't met in two
years
we can call them and say are you are you
want to be active are you what are you
doing you know give us give us give us
and we can make a list of those and
start start getting these folks in here
and say you know this is this is the
list well that number may be smaller
than you think because of all the work
that represents of Evil's
um group could because the last one was
just in
2021 correct 2020. I mean so just just I
mean we had every single
um agency come in and we reviewed every
single statutory commission associated
with those agencies and we did it over a
period of a year and so we just kind of
went through the whole filtering out
process so as
and said there's probably fewer of them
than you might think so last meeting
what what we what we sort of agreed was
that our first task what we would try to
do is
um tackle
the template idea first because we have
another filing period coming up in
September so to the extent that we could
help build the tools here
um first to try to dampen things down in
the future because we just did all the
other review work then maybe we could uh
we could turn to that
just as far as being useful but the
other thing is in our statute every that
we just passed every February 15th and I
know it may take a while to get there
but ever no every January 15th we're
supposed to have the compendium prepared
of all the statutory commissions that
exist so that that tool is available to
everybody and so I know you guys are
working on that
um I was just I had talked to a couple
of people one of the problems I think is
figuring out when these commissions are
meeting because not all all of them are
noticed in our calendar a lot of them
are but I was hoping maybe in working
with I.T some of this information would
be automatically populated in your
compendium so that like Pam and and
Deborah didn't always have to be calling
to see when they had met last
that is part of the plan in creating
this as representative evil just
referred to it the compendium
of where all these groups are meeting
and and as Dave referenced it was much
easier before kovid to figure out after
kova we had a special
Senate President and the speaker at the
time came up with a special plan that
all of the uh commissions needed to be
housed by the agencies because our staff
was trying to support the standing
committees at that time and that did
work out and then we haven't transferred
back in so we don't have as and as we
all know we now have the double rooms so
we don't have as many meeting spaces as
we once had upstairs for these study
commissions
and some of the goals when the study
commissions are created as you know it's
it's to get the agency to start looking
at something so it makes sense that the
the staff of an agency they are the
experts to work with these commissions
so that has evolved as well so we so
it's what I always tell people you know
we have the pre-covered the covet and
the post covet and we're trying to
combine all of that together and we're
still in this huge learning curve
everyone representing people came up
remember that day January 15th and how's
everything report I just stared at her
box I think maybe more like a meltdown
delicate
because we were trying to figure out
appointment stuff and I just wondered uh
whether it's been done I mean the other
thing I would say is to throw some
responsibility on the people who belong
to these commissions and even the
agencies to say hey look this thing has
run its course I mean and not just keep
you know I don't know just realize that
you haven't met you know I don't know if
I was appointed to something or maybe if
people are appointed to something and it
doesn't meet for six months maybe flag
it to the speaker's office
so I think what we can do as soon as we
can when um Deborah's going to be
meeting with Jennifer and I this week
and we're going to look at this and we
will get that list if we don't get the
entire massive uh flow chart to you we
certainly will get those that have not
met so you will have that list and if
you look in your binder you will see the
reports from representative evil and
you'll see in the report the
questionnaires that were created for
these different commissions to say to
ask them when have you met what have you
done and
um that might be something you might
want to consider is creating something
like that again
um for those leftovers that that never
um
uh that we never get an answer from the
last uh study and so we will see where
that is and also in your binder you will
have a list of current
um
studies that are being created right now
and the breakdowns according by is
listed by committee so um that's
something for you to see what we what
we're creating right now to add to our
list but I wouldn't be surprised if if
there may be only
10 or 20 minutes 20 might be July maybe
10 commissions out there that have not
met
well and I was just going to say what we
found when we were going through the
committee on the other committee on
committee's processes some
it's not always a good test whether they
have met or not because some only are
convened under very special
circumstances yeah I mean they're they
they perform a specific function so I
mean there's all ways of of looking at
it so I think we're going to have two
like we we want to have a really well or
easy to research Archive of existing
study committee reports and then an easy
to access list of the commissions that
exist
right so we've got two things going on
here so and I think what representative
evil said is she said the last one took
um about a year it is a slow slower
process than you than you might think
because we want to do this right so
instead of creating little lists here
and there we're trying to create that
master so that we can all have access to
it and that it's it's integrated within
our electronic system so everyone can
look so Courtney can just look up oh
there were three studies on saus in the
last five years and years the fourth I
remember one of the biggest ones we had
was on um
maybe about 15 years ago we had a Civics
study House Education
um it was a chapters no it was a
statutory that was two years long and
was an outstanding study because as
representative Abel said so a lot of
these commissions really they're really
worth it yes you have if you have the
right combination and the right chair
you can do a great job of a study and
this this was an outstanding study and
the department of Ed worked with it and
and all different um schools throughout
the state and then after
um they were so proud of their product
and the report was out and everybody was
very happy and then the next filing
period
two new Civics bills came in and the The
Freshman had no idea the study had just
been completed
um but that also helps when you have
as we've mentioned if the chairs get the
reports then they can ask if the bill
for a study comes before then they can
ask the sponsor well are you aware of
these studies and that will help but so
if we have these
um
the a suggestion for OLS if they have
um not guidelines but questions that
they can ask the uh sponsors and then if
it goes through that level then it would
get a standing committee then you can be
asked again
um and it's just what I've said before
no one all the staff wants to do the
work that's what our job is we love our
job or we wouldn't be here as long as
we've been here and the issue is the
vehicle that we're using sometimes
commissions can be unwilly as as
representable and representative is
mentioned
um
often getting the appointments as we
know there was a Senate bill that just
went through waves and means and and
there's no appointing authority or three
or four of the appointments to be made
and
how do you it's going to be up to the
clerk's office start calling around
calling different groups trying to find
people who are willing to serve and that
takes a lot of Staff time
um when if you have these other
procedures in place
it just would make more sense
well and you know
I think the
Pollyanna or whatever but the real goal
here is to produce studies that are used
and useful because they can be so good
and in many cases they're the generators
of really good legislation looking ahead
and and you know to do good for our
state I mean one of my concerns is that
we not like kill off studies that could
be generating really really good
information you just want to I don't
know you just want to fine-tune the
process so we we get the information to
the people that need it and everybody
gets to use the really good stuff that
comes out
um and I mean I think that's we can't I
don't want to get so mired in details
that we don't lose sight of that
ultimate goal yeah
I think what you just said
representative evil is really key to the
whole conversation in terms of
fine-tuning because that is what was on
my mind
um with the it piece also is that a good
75 85 I'm not sure you know I don't have
an exact figure of the dockets are in
there yes you have to be able to find
them which could be a challenge but it's
really you know that small percentage of
um of entities that don't dock it with
us that don't schedule in the house
calendar that we don't have their
information and so it's having that 100
complete list that is so challenging so
a lot of that infrastructure is played
in place but it needs to go to the next
level and it needs to be 100 complete
so we have a lot of the pieces but it a
lot of it is an exercise and fine-tuning
because we want to be at that next
100 level well isn't that that saying
the last 10 percent it's 90 of the time
I mean I'd be happy with 90.
but and Jen just reminded me one other
item I wanted to mention which we talked
about at our first meeting is that these
study commissions there's there's no
oversight at any level so we had one
study commission where the chairman
um just asked a member of the audience
to write the final report
so now the commission members
participated and they had no idea that
we have designed a template and the
process of how things
um are how we circulate through funnel
reports to all of the named entities
within the legislation and uh when
thankfully another member was on that
commission and came to me let me know
about so I reached out to this outside
person I found through an agency
who was great they sent me something it
was a beautiful booklet all in full
color but I had to explain to me she
really should have the bill number the
chapter number the RSA you need all of
this reference but it was just um a
gentleman who was seeing the audience
and the chair said would you be willing
to write the report because he had shown
up at every meeting but there's no one
to say you you don't we don't have that
infrastructure to say this is our
process because once they are created as
Jen said they have no reason to come
back to us for any kind of assistance
um
yes but I mean I think that's part of
our job too is to sort of put I mean and
I think you guys do have something that
you give first name members on but
really like beef that up and then I mean
I think we put the best infrastructure
in place that we can and they're going
to be people who are far less organized
than other people are less experienced
and it's not you know that just has to
be managed on a personality by
personality basis but for the most part
you should have you know we should try
to have the infrastructure in place so
that you can do your jobs
yes and this is the first time with the
creation of this committee this is the
first time that we have this overall
look at the entire process Beyond just
looking at the legislation excuse me at
the study committees that need to be
examined or commissions to see if
they're meeting this is again the whole
process and bring all offices together
and that's really important and I think
that um this this is one of the most
important pieces that you will be
working on because it'll affect all of
us
um for a long time
yes
thank you
just an observation from my viewpoint I
was on a commission it was it was a good
commission the uh alcohol tourism
Commission
a couple of years ago
and we had great meetings we had great
people everybody from all the alcohol
Industries including the Liquor
Commission and uh
three people from
Commerce at a senator
and we had meetings and it was November
election time
and the chair of the commission did not
get reelected
there was no
document written at the end he just said
too bad
he he actually he he was told he could
not do anything he said you no longer
exist and that's we all we were all
there we saw it happen but there was no
line of succession to write the report
it's it's very fortunate that everybody
in the alcohol industry took the ideas
that we had that were going to be in the
final report and these bills have come
through the house through the Commerce
Committee since then and 95 percent of
our ideas are now in the law but there
was no final report ever written and
that drove me up the wall and my
Democratic counterpart on it drove us
both up the wall because there wasn't in
everybody's going where's the where's
the where's the report where's the
report and we go
the chairman never wrote the report
well that does happen representative
petusic when you have when you cross
over that's why that November 1 deadline
has always been suggested because if you
moved past an election
they're no longer here or if you missed
that deadline
it no longer exists and we've had
members or you don't get a quorum by
then representative McConkey spent a
year and a half trying to get a quorum
and he never he never did did he put it
on there Doc Bill and he just kept
calling and calling and he was just
he could not meet and then we've had
what we do is we do when the members
cannot get a quorum and they're past the
deadline for their report we have a
letter that they just write a letter I
never was able to get a quorum
um or for whatever reason and this is my
final report there is no report
thank you Ian
I'm sorry to interrupt I was just going
to say that's another good question
though for people that want to do these
things what do you plan to use with the
result
what what is your ultimate goal with do
you plan to introduce legislation I mean
why are you
doing I mean it seems obvious in a way
but you know that might
yeah well and then the Committees will
have a huge role in sort of vetting all
these things too but
good okay thank you everyone
I think we definitely dug Into the
Depths where we needed to dig and we got
some information and we're basically
waiting with beaded breath for that
compendium of committees and commissions
so is there any other business to come
before this
I have a question actually before thank
you so much for representative wall and
represent well could you just like
update us on this um is it Senate Bill
84 which is on the commissions yes so um
the plan of uh ledge admin on SB 84 is
we're going to retain that and uh
we created a subcommittee
so the subcommittee will take what we do
here
and put it in SB 84.
excellent
I fully agree with what was just said
um we need to get moving on getting
something done uh we've been given a
load of information even today
we already have some concept of
legislation we'll be needing to file in
terms of the bills that commissions
rather and committees that have been set
up if we can get a list of what's
functioning what's not we need to get
right down to work on figuring where we
can go with that we have a whole host of
things we need to be working on so I
think we need to single out what we're
going to do first
and move forward on that I would like
very much for us to get that list of uh
if we can as soon as possible as to
which commissions are meeting and which
ones are not
and see where we can go with that what
do you think I think right I agree I
mean I think that's good I'd still say
that I think the thing that we really
really need to do is figure out um our
policies for people that are going to be
trying to form these things in September
we have two yeah and they really do go
together
but we're being proactive on one and
reactive on the other and right now uh I
just have one other question I and I
don't even know if this is possible
but to put in the bill SB 84 is there
something that we could say if a
committee or commission hasn't filed a
report in the last three years or met in
the last three beers they're going to
automatically be repealed
yes yes we can
I'm pretty sure we could
um I'm getting a lot of yeah from senior
staff here saying yes we can do that and
that would be an excellent idea I mean
the only thing I would say is that if
you I mean I know there are many
commissions
um they have a repeal date built in so
well I mean they might yeah the new ones
going forward after yeah last 12 1296
was it yeah so they should they'd have a
five-year repeal date I mean it kind of
depends on what they haven't but for the
other ones
I get I you know depending on what their
responsibilities are I mean that's like
you said that there's some that have to
stay in because they meet periodically
so they won't they're not going to have
I mean there are commissions that review
issues
that are less study and more oversight
do you know what I mean so they don't
issue reports as part of their
charge but if they are supposed to issue
reports as part of their charge and they
haven't then
because they're obviously not doing
their jobs right I mean it's another way
okay
we missed anything you guys we good
we're just going to do that just want to
offer this up peripherally something we
probably don't talk enough about and
it's not specific to writing legislation
or having an issue we need to do a
better job no matter what side of the
aisle no matter what side of the wall or
on the cultural component and
representative Cole fault spoke to it
about not hurting somebody's feelings
about keeping their bill alive we need
to message this correctly we we can't be
spending every six years putting
together a committee like this
to address commissions and committees
that shouldn't have necessarily been
into some great like was spoken about
but we need to do a better job job
collectively and globally in the State
House of uh looking at this and
making the decisions not to just
perpetuate
what could be uh legislation gets killed
off let's just
call out the elephant in a room yeah
yes representative
direction from community
I think it's you know I know that's the
messaging of that I guess probably had
its own challenges but I I think
representative Sheen's point about
building in the repeal date seems like
the most straightforward best way we
could weed out a lot I mean that would
just be a default then if you could put
in a carve out for some sort of appeal
process or committees that for whatever
reason aren't meeting but there's a
purpose for them to you know that they
can justify continue to exist but it
would it would they would just go away
under that sort of legislation right
otherwise
yes
speaking briefly to that
I'd love to see that the set in law
contingent repeals or saying that these
things were repealed if they haven't met
that's essentially a contingent repeal
are very difficult for us to deal with
on the end when it comes to revising the
code now we don't do that our publisher
does that but we will get questions from
the publisher we've got probably 20
Pages this year what about this not
commission necessarily but some other
program that was contingently repealed
or Sunset and we can't necessarily
answer unless we do some additional
research
many programs are also
uh
prospectively Sunset unless
a commissioner certifies that XYZ has
done
we've and usually that certificate in
the law it says that I'm supposed to get
copy of that certification but very
frequently do not I can tell you in the
past six years I've probably gotten two
letters of certification regarding
something like that when every session
we have that language put into a bill so
those sort of things that
contingent have contingencies are very
difficult on the back end
making sure that the code is updated
correctly because we do not in our
office get that information
so I would advocate for something in the
in the bill itself in the law itself
having that repeal uh would be much more
preferable
thank you thank you okay um yes and I I
think it's really imperative that every
chairman of every committee and every
ranking member of every committee
um get ready to instruct our fellow
committee members uh what should and
shouldn't be done prior to filing
because it's coming up in September
right even if we don't have that little
brochure or whatever we're looking for
the handout we should all be on the same
page in terms of what can be filed what
should be filed if we're having a
commission or a committee yeah we should
stay have a stated purpose a really
definite purpose for why they're meeting
be very careful who we have appointed to
the commission or committee I still
don't want to drag people and from the
Departments and agencies except to come
and give information not to be members
of those commissions and such
um I have a sunset provision if need be
but give them a specific framework in
which to work and I think that our
members will appreciate being
enlightened and updated on whatever
information we can give them prior to
filing for next year thank you
yeah and then the other thing is to do
what ledge admin is doing I mean
committee standing committees are
empowered to do ad hoc
studies of things it doesn't always have
to be a study committee I mean it's hard
because everybody's busy but you don't
if if a committee really wants to study
something maybe one of the things the
chair asks right off the bat is shall we
study it ourselves because nine times
out of ten if it's on a certain subject
area a lot of the Reps who are assigned
to a study committee are going to come
from the particular committee anyway
like a landfill committee or something
it'll come from Ena just to pick a name
and I agree that yeah we have the
different
and we have subcommittees and we charge
like the insurance department to do this
don't set up a subgroup we charge them
to do this and come back and talk to us
done and and different committees have
different cultures yeah right so that's
how they should take lessons from John
yeah
jerem I agree in our paperwork it says
Legend men for example
um Ken setup and I caught committee or
two or three or whatever is necessary
it's a small committee though
um for studying certain things but
there's a limit as to what you can ask
members to do as well so it all keeps
going back to the original filing the
purposes the restrictions if you might
say are the guidance on what these
commissions and committees need and get
on with it you know set deadlines just
do this and what you can't do we can we
can
resubmit to continue that process but at
the same time if they know that there's
a timeline in which to get something
done I think people often really try
very hard to accomplish that thank you
okay
thank you everybody it's been a great
meeting I think we got some ideas to go
forward and we'll see you in one week at
1300 hours okay
eastern Daylight Savings Time yeah uh